okay my way we're playing this game
about jazz club she has punk I know I
don't really know much about jazz but I
know a lot about being punk okay that's
s oh we must be like India or something
with us the splitters Oh Manchester one
but oh no what is that ok necro phone
that games that presents um okay that
shiz I choose the checking all
electronics book that was a body oh this
is the kind of work
hair
Oh
Oh like us can't if you can spare me
okay it's a spinal at this final ok
let's much data oh ok I mean I mean I'm
in here Thanks ok I must just got out ok
I can't get in here um darling Ted good
kid what is this I'm just a box leave me
alone ok sorry what's going on over
there they hear a lot of stuff you're
typing and I won't stand for it um who's
typing so much Oh what is this oh thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you for sale a car's called like
everyday day saxophone lessons of people
have taken I'm sorry I get prissy to sit
down ok I'm waiting Bruce articles
scanning and I yes sir ok out of here
rally yeah please obviously we march
business to discuss how it shades us yes
it is a town oh it wasn't a place Italy
you need you say for fighter Soviet
homes way ok
and taking some of our important
technology it's imperative we get back
on the right hands and licking at it
away as per usual usual mr. awesome
scripture don't pipe to money if you
need me I'll be in the wine cellar ok
yes preset guy ok oh oh hey he's just
down there I gotta take this Wraith on a
pharmaceutical I can take one capsule
every mission or until reality it's
officially augmented ok machine Oh aunt
bee dexterous ok dr. Howard Dudley all
right well so long sucker isn't look I
change our mind uh oh [ __ ] tuck a
seizure running if we treat the
consulate that's sir
share of me Robin yes but we've gotta be
dropping and so can we got him of a
coffee do you are from the wrong [ __ ]
sorry okay I'll get it I'm sorry can I
Karstark then I get it oh do I look
abroad me there's this yes I can't I
come baby here they come boys yeah it
has stupid it's stupid sucker okay I'm I
needed Michael Fennell the [ __ ] out of
here oh [ __ ] but Papa luge um no sir
what he's bricks it oh congrats you're
the 10 30 feet text arch good good good
good okay um oh it's this alley take
this big also use it to scramble free
carrier frequency pigeons hit each
pigeon three times in order to be Joseph
oh [ __ ] Oh where's brought my twenties
was always drive by quitting online
persona okay okay I could Oh killed him
I gotta I gotta [ __ ] I [ __ ] it up it's
playing jazz now yes yes yes it's all
about agile oh you can blow you crazy oh
you crazy listen brother oh you put it
was really happening again brother I
can't get gettin crazy how can I get
this money too what's in here I see you
back there [ __ ] i stop
ha uneventful there's great about Jesus
okay good good this is all me extra step
receive X will see that for most
effective relief of everything never
take Lucy Beck's after taking arsenal ah
shut earth I really [ __ ] myself over
hello sir my fellow my name is Johnny
too I got an idea is it
sure closer salmon okay I get that I can
understand what if i take that jazz when
you hit that prostitute three that why i
care that much praise it here ma'am oh
good good good okay now I got to get
back to all this these doves I saw one
are in here somewhere it wasn't safe
stole my laptop no no okay where was
that kitchen where was that pigeon
what's over here anything good personnel
razor okay at least you're honest mis
llaves fishing okay something strange is
going on here Oh got you [ __ ] oh sure
BAM what is that Xerox
the [ __ ] was that all units are busy
[ __ ] okay I need their cuffin oh [ __ ]
so that will be your watching my rich in
pigeons pigeons pigeons oh [ __ ] milk
what is this the show is Dottie shortly
I don't want in whenever you feel like
it whatever that they can't get it oh
sure septic is going on here and I need
to know what it is oh [ __ ] yeah sound
for you say something go away leave me
alone go away okay okay um is this
that's out there okay where's the last
picture myself it what is that what do
you need buddy can I help you or roll
big crack in the road oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] murdered him oh so close
oh it's good I'll [ __ ] up now okay
ship is ass [ __ ] scary oh oh oh good
good we did it we did it oh god put it
on okay data packets to crack the
network oh [ __ ] oh I'd no saliva okay
password bunk [ __ ] is that Daddy here Oh
start with together okay we did it yeah
a laptop [ __ ] what is that hell
okay fish and chips okay I'm first in
their pocket edition got you [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay I give you back patent
foramen okay go get back get back really
this pressure
the can I you are a rotten yes yes come
back when you drop of a dolphin the
Korea from a coffin and a coffee do you
have the MacGuffin hey hey hey 10yr
something on my face oh yes yes home ok
I love you bye
okay could I have thee
do you have MacGuffin
this [ __ ] check it yet yeah I'm afraid
you don't have appointment okay sorry oh
god it's so slow is this Oh chef I got
that a political prisoner [ __ ] sorry sir
how beautifully to Cleveland Oh us we
were most popular Christmas what time is
it though it takes six of us ever skits
I can make it good luck shaft
excellent thanks a lot oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
cyborg Hey well done all done y'all are
all suckers
pigeon well well what have we got you
okay good good good a top secret about
need all that stuff but is that ok ok
thought what is this over here oh Jesus
these bricks can these bricks edible
[ __ ] yeah let's kill this bet she say it
complete excellent oh is this gonna got
here okay okay okay okay now what's this
Jesus may fear another month oh sure I
bet this go somewhere oh so need
something yeah sure
Oh guys are legit well done well done
huh what's this guy and play along yeah
I'm getting what oh there's OCA whistle
there oh oh okay
his mistake oh okay set the hand I gotta
target acquired I can how to get here
let's get out of here
Jesus I get the [ __ ] out of here choose
what koi forehead right here little coy
this there's an hour coming isn't a guy
now just lies and just me feeding the
koi Oh welcome back our benefactors were
serious than the ground I hope you're
ready for another job hang out on a
gallon he father engineer working for
Lahey okay install connection sing to
her fully in a particularly valuable all
for some kidney estimated value on the
red markets over 25 billion yen out half
we need you to restart it from him at
any cost okay improvise I know you'll do
well for me they think it was no more
online long to install I can't see how
he is god okay okay okay chuckling now
he loves is like sushi thing okay okay
okay good good gut Yelp's muchacho I'll
rejoin the near back here in a sec oh
shiz areas I really get his kidney
how the cowboy
I can't get their hands out here hello
sorry updatewindow sorry I sure sure
q-ball okay everyone missional cumin bak
oh yeah that's disgusting I can notice
that all disgusting God gonna do it your
all I can take Jesus so no valid but
that's [ __ ] what your house is it guys
ok Oh what you'll study GUI Oh what are
your city I gotta get out of here place
is horrible I can't out what does that
cigarette yessir uh-huh hi hello yes
talking more this bear bite to eat
electric motor oil he says business
someone is here yeah
is it a raging party somewhere oh yes I
will help you
Jesus ass [ __ ] that's your best work
where to get out there this you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you got your [ __ ] Mars you know
what oh [ __ ] I got you this and I got
here [ __ ] is an acquired taste is an
acquired taste okay uh I text back here
okay I'm getting out of here terios this
is favorite man tryin I look at your
three o clock we look soo sick for three
o'clock at an area we both will go kinda
[ __ ] mac and cheese there's just it
ain't happening out there for the TV
looking at me are we put 12 1
this year but she left oh she's a so
sorry oh don't worry i hope you sir the
same
hey the files p hi I'm looking for the
cow man okay um I got you oh hey improve
sorry sorry sir
this is why loves me some sushi oh don't
thing here I don't judge it's a fugu
actually let me keep my shoes on hire a
half we were clean air quotes on like 17
years my grandpa philately be texting
plan is I do have friends kidnapped icy
snow soon again go see Joey again we're
gonna we're gonna get this guy okay what
is this oh ok I got one spider gets
better oh wait a little that's a noise
here okay I got this critter here though
they're gonna find out to do it that's
hit critters here at my face [ __ ] I
can't get through critters here the
critters critters okay I gotta find some
more critters anymore in years i just
want full little so what
okay I looking for critters um critters
it has a critter yeah they supposedly
just like one more critter here excuse
me sir I'm looking for critters here's
one okay didn't I faced [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
plays okay I'm the figure master here
what the [ __ ] and I piss on your hobby
store brightness Holly oh I have been
defiled okay oh [ __ ]
he took every play this is disgusting
hey just getting it all [ __ ] out I'll
go boy soon oh that's disgusting I need
like a weapon I need a weapon I need to
kill him [ __ ] I'll get hugging him
that's easy sir oh god where is a thick
girls room oh my god he just [ __ ] out
skillfully I got the kid named target
card how'd I get out of here now would
you like me to enjoy well duh there all
done
ash n handle the wet weather and we
won't do something ridiculous at my face
sold it you owe me but you need to [ __ ]
all you better get out of here oh no are
they blocking roshambo
anything we're just know it that's [ __ ]
I need to get out of here look you all
the way that's nice I got CSU not this
particular folder
I can only they read book value for this
work [ __ ] you betcha oh yes and I just
just made my Sam spot you know oh hey
Jenna okay sorry do you want to join me
umm this is nice this is nice I'd like
to light this candle if I may I can't
thank ya ok I'd like to just like the
burning incense if I may ok ok i
achieved enlightenment hello sir now you
are here so notice
okay do I knocked up light the incense
okay good get gifts and now okay oh good
okay I'm here I'm here fantastic work
not only am i fighting to the pod that
last job seems you attracted us a bit
more heat than usual after wait for
things to cool down a bit yeah it moves
on I'll set you up with a light hunter
that can always fences my trip to cart
up results Nicole that small thing you
look like an angel oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] God
and the worst pilot ever look at a [ __ ]
I'm kind of a daddy there we go we made
it to contact resort okay um we're gonna
end it here on our vacation and I'm
Rebecca later I can thanks for checking
of guys